this annual lecture celebrates the
Norman Alexander foundations generous
endowments to establish the normani
Alexander library of Jewish Studies and
also to establish a position for the
first librarian for Jewish Studies at
Columbia it's a post capably and
expertly held by michelle chaz nur a
third Alexander endowment supports the
libraries Rare Book and Manuscript
Holdings including important Judaica
resources and Hebrew manuscripts and
it's one of the largest collections in
the country we have digitized and made
available online more than 200 of these
manuscripts in their entirety in
addition to celebrate in celebrating the
normani Alexander Foundation's great
gift to Columbia's libraries on this the
10th anniversary of that gift this
annual lecture also signifies the
library's enduring commitment to
supporting the field of Jewish Studies
at Columbia I want to thank especially
Norman Alexander's daughter Gail Ben
Derman who is with us tonight for her
enthusiasm in support of the collections
and all of its related programs thank
you so much Gary and now I present the
Norman Alexander librarian for Jewish
Studies Michele Chesney who will
introduce tonight's speaker this lecture
is sponsored annually by the libraries
and gratitude to the generous gift at
the Alexander foundation in sponsoring
the Normandy Alexander library for
Jewish Studies this year as Anne said is
the 10th anniversary of the Foundation's
gift which was awarded to Columbia
University Libraries in 2008 the
Alexander foundation provided funding
for the first librarian of Jewish
Studies at Columbia as well as special
funds for both general and Special
Collections it is a direct result of
this gift that Columbia's Judaica
collection has achieved worldwide
prominence and has been able to continue
to grow and contribute significantly
within the world of Jewish Studies I
remember when I first mounted when I
mounted my first exhibition into
and 12 I was questioned as to why I
quote JT s's manuscripts were on exhibit
at Columbia I explained to the
dumbfounded visitor that in fact these
wonderful collections actually did
belong to these this institution and in
many cases had been there even before
the Jewish Theological Seminary was
established I don't get those kinds of
questions so much anymore before I
introduce our speaker tonight I must
acknowledge the tragic timeliness in the
title of tonight's lecture so soon after
a particularly horrific shooting so
close to home where the shooter
specifically targeted Jews for being
Jews I'd like to take this moment to
wish a speedy recovery to those injured
in Saturday's terrible events and to
remember Joyce Feinberg Richard
Gottfried Rose mallinger Jerri
Rabinowitz Daniel Stein Melvin wax
Irving younger Cecil Rosenthal David
Rosenthal
Bernice Simon and Sylvan Simon thank you
and now I'd like to introduce professor
Benjamin R again pal
professor gam Pal is the Dina and Ellie
field family chair in Jewish history at
the Jewish Theological Seminary a
scholar of medieval Sephardic Jew II
professor compels most recent book is is
anti-jewish riots in the crown of Aragon
and the royal response 1391 to 1392
which won the 2016 national but Jewish
Book Award for scholarship
professor Gamble is proud to be amongst
salaburu pne's
academic grandchildren having studied
with Barone's students V and Corey is
more sure SH Arthur Hertzberg and yes if
you Rochelle me we look forward to
hearing professor Gaughan pal discussed
Barons legacy in re embracing the
lachrymose has the theory of Jewish
history dialogue with a Columbia
tradition hi everyone it's absolutely
wonderful to be here to be able to
return to Columbia and to speak about
professor Barone that's an extraordinary
opportunity and an honor
particularly heartened that my
colleagues are in this room my teachers
my family my friends and heartened by
the fact that Saylor Barone's legacy is
of interest to so many of us Columbia
was formative in my academic training
some of what I teach what I continue to
teach and how I think was formed on this
campus so thank you for having me it's
lovely to be here
Salo Barone ah
the first occupant of the military coup
is history literature and institutions
at Columbia was arguably the founder of
Jewish historical studies in the United
States and I imagine that no one will
give me an argument especially here this
evening
that Salo Barone additionally was one of
the most influential Jewish historians
of the 20th century he was born in 1895
to a wealthy family in Galicia in
southeastern Poland in torna and Tarn al
and as many Galician Jews prior to World
War one he moved to Vienna and at the
university of vienna he earned three
doctorates in history political science
and law and he received an advanced
Jewish education in that city as well
the Jewish Institute of religion under
the leadership of rabbi Stephen wise
invited him to come to the United States
in 1926 he was lured away from the
Jewish Institute of religion in 1929 to
occupy the Miller chair Salo Barone was
not American was not born here but he
made America his home and he taught here
until his retirement in 1963
in 1928 almost 90 years ago Barone wrote
an essay for a leading Jewish periodical
the Manohar journal which he entitled
ghetto and emancipation 90 years ago and
it's ideas still resonate today it was a
revolutionary article and in the space
of 90 years people have quibbled with so
many aspects of it but it was
breathtaking Barone decided and
announced to American Jews he was
writing for the manova journal he was
not writing in an academic forum and he
announced to American Jews that they
misunderstood the meaning of ghetto and
emancipation ghetto was had a negative
valence Jews being locked in at night
lack of freedom lack of movement lack of
an inability to intellectually explore
an emancipation civil rights ah our
dream our dream to join the external
society to gain the benefits from the
culture around us to succeed every
minorities fantasy that will be like
them we'll learn from them will grow
barone flips our understanding of ghetto
and emancipation the ghetto was not that
bad the ghetto allowed the Jews to
thrive the ghetto allowed the Jews to
create an extraordinary social fabric
yes there were disabilities but he
argued that this these disabilities
failed to the disabilities that other
individual
experienced in pre traditional society
Barone argued that the Jews were far
more economically successful than others
sure they suffered from restrictions but
less than most even their social lives
were richer Barone also spoke about the
emancipation the emancipation he said
was not a golden age Barone was
crucially aware already in 1928 that the
destruction of the ghetto walls the
citizenship granted to the Jews much was
lost
especially the institutional corporate
embodiment of Jewish autonomy the Jewish
community and Barone said and at that
point in 1928 presciently that he sees
no reason to imagine that modernity
would be safer for the Jews then the
medieval world so disposed Salo Barona
pined about the Middle Ages surely it is
time to break with the lachrymose theory
of pre-revolutionary whoa and to adopt a
view more in accord with historic truth
Barone would make his name on this anti
lachrymose theory that was his
propelling idea Jewish history is not a
veil of suffering it is not endless
sadness and frankly also it is not
simply a period of suffering and
rabbinic literature there is more to
Jewish life than that but Rome was
dedicated already from 1928 to attempt
to prove to Jews to America if you will
to the world
to the West that Jewish history followed
the same rules as all other people's
history and that Jewish life can be seen
in many respects as a success so
motivated Barone investigates the social
and religious history of the Jews and in
1937 many of you know he publishes his
social and religious history in three
volumes on medieval Jewish history which
is my focus this evening Barone
gay gives us three chapters on the
medieval Jewish experience how does he
take his anti lachrymose conception and
how does he work it out in terms of the
actual Middle Ages well in his first
chapter on the video period the last
chapter in Volume one he entitled
infidel seems like a startling title for
somebody who was looking on and looking
for the successes of the Jews in it he
describes Islam as a dynamic force the
Caliphate culturally and economically
superior to the Byzantine Empire and
mentions that the Jewish people
quickened and entered another period of
great achievement barone was not blind
the anti-jewish animus barone says
openly Islam was by no means friendly to
Judaism but Barone had a sweeping
panoramic view although the Jews had the
status of infidels he still felt that
their status was envy viewable compared
to the Christians compared to others
when we as historians today look back at
Barone's chapter on Islam we know far
much more of course than barone did
thanks
the researchers in the Ganesa but this
vision of Jews under Islam especially
during its first few centuries as being
a time of economic and religious
vitality has remained with us and vol.2
Barone has a captor called the wanderer
Jews and Christian Europe o Barone does
not turn a blind eye oh not to the
economic decline of Jewish traders he
doesn't turn a blind eye to their
elimination from agriculture to the
difficulties Jews had with guilds to the
relatively few periods of affluence but
Barone continues to argue that there are
positive moments Jewish serfdom which
was seen prior to Barone as being the
absolute nadir of Jewish life Barone
argues a Jewish serfdom is an aspect of
protection and that the Jews thrived in
Christian Europe and he continues on
Baronne argues that it's not the church
that is the enemy of the Jews but rather
who was late to nationalism I must say
reading this chapter again we do see
sailor Barone having greater challenges
trying to make sense out of this period
then he did under Islam it's a very very
difficult period for him to put a rosy
face on Baronne almost when you read him
you get a sense of what his later
writings were to be he just simply is
speaking and writing on and on without a
clear thesis but desperate to prove that
Christians and Jews and especially the
Jewish life was positive
Barone really saved his greatest
contribution I think in the first volume
in his chapter entitled within the
ghetto walls there Barone comes to life
continuing his assault on the lachrymose
theory by focusing on the Jewish
corporate status the technical ghetto
proud of the great success of Jewish law
as he says rabbinic social philosophy
strengthened solidarity so necessary to
the people's struggle for survival he
praises scholasticism and surprisingly
reading it again
he is enamored with Kabbalah and he sees
Jewish mysticism as a sign that Jewish
life and Jewish intellectual life is
thriving just from reading 1937 the
social and religious history we begin to
get a sense of what Barone is after yes
Barone is dedicated to an anti
lachrymose conception of Jewish history
but at the same time Barone is aware of
the evidence and he's attempting to
incorporate evidence of attacks on Jews
of difficulties that the Jews had within
and still remaining with this anti
lachrymose conception the second edition
of verone's work he started in 1951
started publishing it in 1952 it
extended to 18 volumes Barone and others
have said it before me simply did not
know how to stop he was so dedicated so
propelled by this anti lachrymose theory
that he spends volume after volume
charting Jewish life in a sweeping
geographical
ramaa Varon concludes and really he
doesn't he leaves it for us to conclude
that Jewish life in the Middle Ages was
something to be envied in the second
edition I would argue it becomes clear
what was at stake for Barone and his
argument for the anti lachrymose
conception of Jewish history for sale of
Barone although trained as a modernist
medieval Jewish history was his model
Barone started to write in the shadow of
the period after World War one the idea
of Jews and others having minority
rights in this new post-world War one
period that Jews would have the benefits
of citizenship but yet at the same time
enjoy a kind of communal life if you
will a modified medievalism is what
stimulated him the Rome was dedicated to
prove that medieval Jewish life was a
life that people could imagine was
something that Jews could be well be
proud of what I'd like to continue to do
this evening is thank you is to focus on
the medieval period
and test out whether Barone's comments
were correct is an anti lachrymose
perception of medieval Jewish history
appropriate does it stand up over time
is Barone's particular attitude off-base
Jews in the medieval period lived under
Christianity and lived under Islam under
Christianity and Islam Jews played a
role within these dominant religions
theology the role they played within
these other religions theology often led
to negative perceptions of the Jews
indeed as we know attacks on Jews but
Barone was also mindful of and correct
in understanding that it's precisely
because the Jews mattered to
Christianity and mattered to Islam that
the Jews were also protected and that
the Jews were also able to create an
extraordinary communal life let's turn
our attention now to one geographical
area an area I know a bit about turn our
attention to the Iberian Peninsula in
the Middle Ages and see specifically if
Barone's arguments seem to be justified
the I've been peninsula is an
interesting place to test out Barone's
hypothesis after all this is an area
this is an arena this is a time period
where Jews have imagined that life was
exceptional starting already in the 19th
century Jews perceived about their life
within the Iberian Peninsula that it was
a golden age that was extraordinary
there's a
time of great Jewish religious vitality
there is a time of great Jewish success
politically it was a time of cultural
creativity and in fact that fantasy is
not simply only the fantasy of Jews it's
the fantasy of all those who study the
Iberian Peninsula Spanish Portuguese
historians even today
imagine a convivencia starting from the
early 20th century in America Castro
imagine a convivencia with Jews
Christians and Muslims live together and
diffuse each other with their ideas it's
almost like a playground for an
imagination that life could be good even
in times where there are dominant
monotheism but a closer look at the Jews
of Iberia
closer look at what was later called
Sephardic jury already begins to suggest
to us that this image of a Golden Age
cannot be sustained even during the
Muslim period when the Jews were welcome
at court and the Jews created an
exceptionally original Jewish culture
even during those times a careful study
of the literature indicates to us if the
Jews were less than sanguine about their
future that anxiety propelled them that
they were aware that their status in
their fate sometimes hung by a thread
the great Shmuel Hanavi eyed the zere
perhaps to the king of granada
if Moshe Ibanez correct oh so
commander-in-chief of the armies of
Granada sure well Hannah GERD is
successful and yet with his son takes
over his position from him after shell
dies
yosef perhaps in a wrong political
choice
is murdered and Jews are killed in the
streets of Granada at the central point
of the Golden Age it's quite clear that
Jewish status is not something that can
be relied upon
Jews become aware during the Islamic
period that the reasons for success are
contingent upon their service to the
king and with a misstep all of the
accomplishments of the Jewish courtier
could simply dissolve the Muslims who
had provided a home for the Jews a
cultural intellectual home also began to
turn on the Jews in the late 11th and
12th centuries the coming of the
Almoravids the almohads and jewish life
became more more marginal under islam we
moved to the Christian period Jews at
first are successful the Jews are
mediators between Christianity and Islam
they are managers financial managers for
the kings and queens the Jews are
diplomats the Jews are successful
traders did you achieve great prominence
in the 13th century as the Jews are seen
by the Christians as allies against the
hated Muslims but the success is
fleeting as well even in the midst of
this success Jewish status is under
attack if we follow for example the
history of our pawns of the 10th Alfonso
Savio Alfonso who had Jews within his
court Jews who were crucial in his
cultural attempts to transfer the
knowledge of the greco-roman world from
Islam took Christendom the same Alfonso
the tenth turns on the Jews towards the
end of his life and Jews are held for
ransom
and the Jewish community is seriously
harmed the great James the first James
the Conqueror who has Jews controlling
the royal treasury the great James the
first who includes the Jews in the
highest realms of his kingdom it's the
same James who already in 1240 forces
Jews to listen to sermons and as well
stages a public discus station in Chris
with Christians in Barcelona starting
the history of the Jews in the Iberian
Peninsula starting the history of thus
far Adam we can revel in the Jews
successors we can be mindful of their
accomplishments but we're also aware at
the same time at the same moment of the
fragility of their lives
we wonder whether the anti lachrymose
conception is convincing can we really
think that the Jews even in a country
and over a time period which is
considered to be a hallmark of Jewish
accomplishment whether indeed Jews can
be seen as living a full and rich life
I've spent the last number of years
focusing on a decidedly sad event in
Jewish history at the end of the 14th
century the Jews of Spain in Castile and
Aragon were subject to attacks Jews a
massacred in Castile Jews are killed in
the crown of Aragon
the links that the Jews had made with
governmental authorities have not served
to protect them but I don't want to use
moments of attacks specifically to
debunk if you will Barone's thesis
Barone was aware of violence of the
Jewish communities there had always been
violence but what I do want to focus on
is that the Jews during the attacks
appeal to the royal authorities time and
again and with the Jews realizes the
minority people were that they simply
weren't high on the governmental agenda
what 1391 in the events of 1391 proved
to the Jews if they needed any clarity
at all is that their life that their
live as a minority group were dependent
and dependent upon others and dependent
upon other people who did not see them
necessarily as the most valuable asset
in the royal domain and as far as Jews
and successful Jews at the court we find
that the great hasta chriskiss wonderful
Jewish philosopher leader of the Jewish
community who fought valiantly on behalf
of the Jews at the court pleading with
the Monarchs to intervene that he
ultimately was not effective not only
wasn't the effective but even his
attempts to save his own son were
unsuccessful
this doesn't seem to be a time perdu we
could speak about comfortably focus on
Jewish power rather what we're aware of
is not only Jews being harmed but also
Jewish political impotence in many
respects I'm the student of sal Barone
I root the history of the Jews as he did
as well within the governments and
societies in which the Jews lived I'm
led to pursue the social history of
which Barone preached for and yet what
were left with
were left with a sense of emptiness all
of you sitting here I imagine know that
in the end of the 15th century the Jews
were expelled from the kingdoms of the
Iberian Peninsula first in 1492 from
Castile and Aragon in 1496 seven from
Portugal in 1498 from Navarre and there
in my first book Barone's influences
present my goal was in the first book to
show that even on the eve of this last
expulsion the Jews had a successful
economic life
the Jews continued to live as if they
had lit as they have lived in decades
prior
that even on the eve of catastrophe or
possible looming catastrophe the Jews
always trusted in the ongoing nature of
their community so if the medieval
period and even the medieval period in
Spain is a period where yes there were
Jewish successes yes there were
extraordinary cultural achievements but
yes at the same time there was a
vulnerability that was experienced by
the Jews on a daily basis how can we
begin to appreciate what Barone was
trying to do Barone in 1928 was
determined was determined to prove that
a Jewish community a Jewish community
even just granted minority rights under
other governments that that kind of a
Jewish community could be a model for
the contemporary period he kept to those
ideas he strikingly kept to those ideas
even after the destruction of European
Jewry in the twentieth century and even
after the rise of the State of Israel in
1963 in his essay newer emphases in
Jewish history he wrote all my life I
have been struggling against the
hitherto dominant lachrymose conception
of Jewish history a term which I've been
using for more than 40 years because I
have felt that an overemphasis on Jewish
sufferings distorted the total picture
of the Jewish historical evolution and
at the same time badly served the
generation which had become impatient
with the nightmare of endless
persecutions in massive
indeed the entire project of his second
edition started in 1951 was probably
motivated by the notion that despite
what had just happened
despite the Holocaust despite the rise
of the State of Israel burro was still
committed to the idea that a modified
medievalism was still a possible
possible way for the recreation of
Jewish communities as barone said in
writing after the war the Jews have
learned through their history that they
could live without a state without a
territory and without a language Sayla
barone when you read his volumes in some
respects was correct we should not
overemphasize Jewish suffering we should
have pay attention to Jewish successes
he was correct we need to go country by
country and notice where the Jews lived
and live for periods at a time with
fruitful relationships with their
neighbors
but while Barone is correct what we seem
to miss is we seem to miss the
continuous feeling of Jewish
vulnerability my argument here tonight
is not that barone was wrong in the
sense of his
desire to look upon the positive moments
in Jewish history but rather that his
categories and ways of research thinking
about Jewish history in terms of the
anti lachrymose conception is simply not
useful either for a way of understanding
Jewish history or even for Jewish life
today in our time period now to argue
for an anti lachrymose conception of
Jewish history to try to imagine a past
not only through the veil of Tears is
not necessarily a useful message for the
Jewish community for most American Jews
they're already convinced that Jewish
life is not lachrymose and they're not
inclined to imagine that a modified
medievalism is an answer to their
challenges after the destruction of
European Jewry and the rise of the State
of Israel when West the West and Israel
realities of Jewish life there are new
governing ideas and paradigms that we
need to welcome and not ones that were
forged in the wake of World War one a
Jewish history which focuses on the fact
that the Jews are continually reliant on
others that that is the fate of a
minority group that they're reliant on
others whether they live within a
Democratic Society or within a sovereign
state those probably are points of view
that need to be stressed I want to
reimburse a lacrimosa
of Jewish history not one of pogroms or
an emphasis on suffering in rabbinic
literature we today can recognize Jewish
history as lacrimosa and at the same
time acknowledge the do Jews social and
religious creativity over time we no
longer need to worry as Jews did maybe a
decade or two ago that lacrima city
could threaten to overwhelm the Jewish
community the Holocaust as we well know
has already lost traction amongst the
Jews its meaning does not necessarily
galvanize the Jewish community while
Barone was right about medieval Jewish
life in the pitfalls of modernity the
Jewish and the Jewish experience was not
one of unrelieved suffering still the
nature of Jewish life in his particular
fears must be newly appreciated a
lachrymose understanding of Jewish
history is helpful we can't afford to be
naive either socially or religiously
what my research on 1391 taught me and I
think teaches all of us that it's not
just the violence that the Jews need to
be concerned about but it's the
impotence and our lack of importance and
those of our intercessors it's
interesting Barone as I said at the
beginning of the lecture wrote the anti
lachrymose theory for a popular Jewish
audience not an academic one and here
strangely I am at Columbia where I'm
speaking to an academic audience about
what might be best for the Jews what the
Jewish historical agenda might or should
be
I think this gives me a time as well to
reflect on the last number of years
since I was a student here when I was a
student here special pleading on behalf
of minorities to sit in a class and to
say openly that you cared about a
particular religious or ethnic group was
looked upon askance was a sign that you
weren't dispassionate that objective
history was not your calling card but in
the last number of years university life
has changed special pleading is no
longer seen that way articulation on
behalf of particular groups is seen
positively you're seeing now is an
engaged historian as a story who cares
about the subjects which he or she
addresses life has changed
Communiversity has changed the existence
of a Jewish librarian is a reflection of
that change so there sailor Barone is in
1928 he's arguing to the Jews yes look
back upon your history it's not a veil
of suffering a culturation is positive
you can create a modified form of a
Jewish community that is your future but
here we are you don't need to prove to
American Jews that acculturation is
positive and it's not a message that
needs to be heard you're so comfortable
in America they succeeded perhaps
oh not an emphasis on lacrimosa tea but
an awareness of it a willingness to
stress it a willingness to say the
Jewish life was vulnerable even at times
of the greatest success that even as I
tapped the glories of Sephardic jury
which I skimmed over it's necessary to
remember that Jewish life even in the
Iberian Peninsula was fraught now
humanities the greatness monies are
participating in the debate in Barcelona
against Pablo Christiani can say in his
commentary on the Torah that he's
writing for the FA galoot to those who
are tired of exile the people who are
tired who are tired of the tension
I come here to pray Salah Barone he
taught my teachers my teacher professor
Shore she's in the audience he taught my
teacher to be on Corre my first
professor of medieval Jewish history he
taught my teacher author Hertzberg the
Maverick historian of the modern Jewish
experience and of Zionism and he taught
my doctor father Yosef you were shown me
who was so proud to have been the
student of Barone yet Barone allowed us
precisely to critique him Barone writes
in his third volume read the last
chapter it's still stirring talking
about historic Midrash the Jewish
history is a text that we constantly
interpret and reinterpret as he writes
in volume 2 the interpretation or
reinterpretation of the history of the
people a kind of historic Midrash is now
to serve as the guidance for the future
Barone was right Jewish history follows
the same rules as the history of other
peoples but we do have our own
variations not that our history is worth
than others not that it's always bad but
let's stop striving to prove the good
try to keep both visions in your mind at
the same time and not just those binary
opposites imagine that you are in the
10th century in sepharad and you're
enjoying the wine and the song and the
garden parties and you're exalting in
the creation of literature and reading
Muslim tomes which give you a sense of
what the Jewish
Rick um should look like and know that
the Jews at the exact same time are
feeling extraordinarily vulnerable that
a poet like do National a brat can use
the term we're still middle C mu Ghulam
we are despised it may mean in the final
analysis when I think about Jewish
history and I think about the success of
minority groups there frankly I don't
accept the simple notion of progress
embraced by the West not eternally
sanguine about the fortunes of the Jews
nor of the world in which we live and
frankly neither was Barone as he
demonstrated in his ghetto and
emancipation essay ever even an
interview in 1985 with the New York
Times as he approaches 90th birthday in
the words of Joseph Berger who was the
interviewer for The Times there's one
crimp and mr. Barone's optimism he right
it is his caution in assessing the
prospects for jury despite its relative
security today he recalled that in Spain
in the 13th century Jews were diplomats
and government leaders yes
yet by 1391 they were experiencing
pogroms and by 1492 they were expelled
they thrived in England in the 11th
century yet by 1290 they too were
expelled quote we can't be too sure such
that things will last he said I don't my
intention here is not an offer at
jeremiad or a crude it can be happen
here kind of rant but at the same time
and President Obama would often quote
Martin Luther King's comment which was
paraphrase from the American
transcendentalist Theodore Parker and
you know the quote let us realize that
the arc of the moral universe is long
but that it bends toward justice at best
this comment is inspirational
perhaps it's aspirational but to my mind
is decidedly untrue history may change
over time but in what direction it
changes is not clear at all
[Applause]
one quibble two questions quibble is I
don't think Manoa Journal was very
popular among Jews it was written for
young intellectuals it was it was okay I
don't know a Jewish not like he wrote
for Newsweek or any or even commentary
god forbid my two questions one is is
unless Peron addressed this period in a
non lachrymose way then it wouldn't
necessarily contradict his larger thesis
about the past thousand years and second
I I've never read a lot about Peron
never read it Barone eighteen volumes
how can those be any good well I'll try
to answer quibbles questions in some
effective way Barone wrote for the
Manohar journal was which was a journal
that was founded and was written for and
supported by young Jewish intellectuals
in the late twenties it wasn't popular
in the sense of mass popularity Barone
wrote about the Middle Ages extensively
in the second edition volumes in volume
10 he spends much time on Iberian Jews
what is so striking about Barone and
still inspiring to me today that
although we know what his ideals were
that he consistently pursued an anti
lachrymose conception he told the truth
about the time the way he saw it he
didn't bury negative events in the
footnotes so if you want to know how he
treated the medieval period he treated
it even-handedly sometimes so
even-handedly the things spiraled out of
control as to how Barone could have
managed it it was an extraordinary
intellect
Barone wrote number of decades ago there
is much we know now that he wasn't aware
of then there's much that can still be
learned from him obviously each
generation comes up with its own
questions and say in content it's fine
oh I'll tell you a story because a
personal story which might go a long way
here I am a young graduate student when
young graduate students maybe there are
some in the room have that wonderful
combination of being meek self effacing
and self-deprecating and at the same
time grandiose with a chip on their
shoulder right before we were about to
criticize our teachers so Salem Salle
Oberon would come marching into the
library at the same time almost every
day looking and flipping through the
boxes in the card catalog and finally
yeah hello professor Barone I walk up
one day I don't tie my jacket I didn't
have such a jacket
but I woke up the first Barone and say
hello probably I said you wrote in
volume 10 page 200 and something or
other X Y & Z and I found it skew L and
G and he looks at me with this
beneficent smile on his face and said
thank you for your communication I'll
make sure to include your latest
research in my next edition Barone knew
that he wasn't the last word he know
that people would continue to search and
research but Barone was the ideal which
we all emulated he told us we need to
know about the history not only of the
Jews but of the surrounding culture and
that's why he spent so much time when I
told him I was going off to Spain to
work in the archives
he was complimentary and then leaned
across the table and said to me pray
Franco lives
Franco was alive then he thought that
when Franco would die that the Civil War
would erupt in Spain again what the
reason why I'm saying this is Barone was
human he was not a prophet it was an
extraordinary historian he trained great
Jewish his stories who in turn trained
me and others in this room we're aware
that Franco died and I was able to
continue my research that doesn't
diminish anything from professor Barone
you mentioned a number of times in
history where Jews lived in relative
comfort same way they lived up until the
time of their expulsion mm-hmm so what
were the warning signs that popped up to
let people know this was happening since
they lived so comfortably up until that
point yes the warning signs
it concerns us doesn't it can we tell
how about if we say that we can't how
about do we say that we can't how about
that we say that later in the distance
we might be able to pick up signs we
weren't aware of now how about if that
is a way to look at Jewish history and
to look at minority history in fact you
helped me with this question because it
brings home precisely why I don't want
to follow the anti lachrymose theory
anymore there the Jews are in our era in
1494 the Jews have been expelled from
Castile and Aragon
there they are in 1497 the Jews have
been expelled from Portugal
and there are no signs that they sell
their property at any higher rate are
they blind no what do you do as a person
as a human being you trust in your
community in this continuity and
sometimes you're right but not always my
lessons from history I have a much less
important question than the one that
preceded it and to what extent it
concerns the historic historiography
that preceded Barone about which I know
absolutely nothing but to what extent
was he responding to a historiographical
sense of black Roma City as opposed to
say a theological or a popular
conception your question is important
and clearly you have wonderful instincts
yes he was responding to previous Jewish
historians he was responding to Heinrich
Gretz in the 19th century who may he may
have unfairly labeled as being marred
within a lachrymose perception of Jewish
history he was responding also to
Simon Dubin off and his communal history
of the Jews sober owned yes was within a
strong European historiographical
tradition that he wished to distance
himself from and he wished to carve out
for himself so there was pushback thank
you I'm just wondering in thinking about
and thinking about Peron he's publishing
18 volumes he's seeking to create a
total conception of Jewish history he's
seeking to create a total thesis and he
really stands between historians in the
late 19th century who are seeking to do
that and in the 20th century where
historians are not where historians are
seeking to do micro history where we're
looking right about 1391 to 13 9 exactly
where our goal is the entire two years
please don't get me wrong I'm the
serious historian where our goal and we
can't necessarily create an all
conceiving conception of of Jewish
history and so to use barone as a
jumping-off points lacrimosa anti
lachrymose is is to understand its
applicability for the specific
historical image that you're seeking to
draw yes it's a very fine point Barone
did attempt total history so than many
historians at that time you're right by
comparing generations and here I say
this Barone failed that his attempt in
the first edition he wrote about the
social and religious history when he got
to the second edition when he got to the
medieval period from volume 3 through
volume 18 was just the social history of
medieval Jews he hadn't begun to write
the religious history that's why when he
said he was going to you
include my later research in his second
edition I didn't run home and
immediately tell my wife but you're
right the attempted total history is not
something that we do pursue now we leave
that right to your Newsweek authors we
leave that to others I think what Barone
was great about was and he as a person
that he was a involved integrated member
of the Jewish community in so far as he
was concerned about Jewish life in
Jewish communities across the world and
that he tried very very hard especially
after the war to recreate some of the
cultural treasures that were lost so
Barone was dedicated to the Jewish
community he wrote as a dispassionate
historian but his essays really reflect
his passion as a Jew and he writes and
one part I'll just have to recreate it
that the reason why in the mid forties
he writes us in Jewish factor in
medieval civilization the reason why he
had to disdain the lachrymose conception
of Jewish history because Jewish pride
got in the way that self pitying Jews
did not attract him and he wanted to
leave that behind and the way he could
leave that behind is by saying look
folks let's not forget that life was
good for many decades and what I'm
saying is yes I who spend my life on ten
years here and ten months there just say
that that is not needed anymore
we're in a different place within the
Jewish community in terms of Jewish
pride in Jewish sensibility and a dose
of lacrima City might be just what the
doctor ordered
okay thank you
[Applause]